- So, hier ist noch meine Handynummer.
- Ist das eine Zwei oder eine Sieben?
- Ehh, das ist eine Sieben …
0173 90 76 34 29 58.
- 0173 90 76 34 29 58.
- Alles klar, danke.
- Ja, hallo! Wie heißt du?
- Nico, wie geht’s?
- Danke, danke, mir geht’s gut.
- Oh, mein Gott …
- Wie geht’s dir?
- Hmm. Nicht so gut.
- Nicht so gut? Warum nicht so gut?
- Meine Tasche. Meine Tasche ...
Tasche verloren ...
- Oh, okay, Moment ...
Du hast deine Tasche verloren?
Wie ist das passiert?
- Hallo?
- Oh, hallo ... Wer bist du denn?
- Eh, Entschuldigung. Ich bin nicht Nico.
Mein Name ist Lisa.
Nico spricht nicht so gut Deutsch.
Er sucht seine Tasche.
Seine Tasche ist schwarz und ...
Eh. Sie hat einen Aufnäher
mit einem Fahrrad.
- Okay.
- Nicos Pass ist in der Tasche.
Also wenn ihr die Tasche findet, dann gebt
sie bitte bei der Polizeistelle Ost ab.
Die ist in der Schreinerstraße 144.
- Scheinerstrasse 144?
- Nein, Schreinerstraße, mit „R“,
S-C-H-R-E-I-N-E-R.
Und die Hausnummer ist die 144.
- Danke euch! Viel Glück!
- Was soll das denn?
- Entschuldigung ...